mike baum and his skydiving buddies are
about to turn a heavy bowling ball into
a lightweight balloon
this bowling ball looks weightless right
it's it looks so easy to just push it
back and forth instead of this really
heavy mass so it just looks really
beautiful and elegant
what's the physics behind this free
falling fun
air resistance changes the rate at which
two different size objects fall through
the air now a bowling ball should slip
through the air quite easily it should
fall faster than they are in the case of
a man he's a much larger object than a
ball so he's going to experience a much
larger air resistance on his body and
that's why he would be falling a lot
slower than a bowling ball
so how they slow down the bowling ball
so they're all falling at the same speed
they attach streamers to that bowling
ball which create a drag air resistance
force that keeps the ball in line
falling at the same rate with all the
flying men without the streamers it
would actually slip through the air and
fall much faster
if they get to the ground and there are
no bowling pins there waiting for that
ball
they've missed an opportunity